houston vous savez quand on ne bouge pas
par le jingle on vous l'a dit en
évoquant le signal
voilà je crois mais qu'est ce qui se
passe et j'ai dans le public on
recommence à fait je chirac dans le
public tu t'approches de sept cas pas de
cuve et surtout non non non non non elle
était elle est élue
les studios vous pensez à quoi là j'ai
toujours tendance à penser un petit peu
à la seconde qui bien que c'est le plus
beau moment de la miss et c'est la
seconde qui le déséquilibre est toujours
vers la seconde suivante oui quand vous
regardez le matin non dans votre mémoire
vous vous dites quoi
j'aime bien non même avant d'ailleurs
j'aimais bien regarder dans les vitrines
ouais parce que il ya des vitrines des
campagnes et des endroits qu'on connaît
et où chaque fois qu'on passe au mondial
oui il ya des belles vies with un ailier
alias est un plaisir
alors que tous les matins quand même
c'est toujours différent quand j'ai
l'habitude c'est chiant quand à dire
regardez tous les matins de nouveau vous
étiez petits milliards sans blake mort
tels que la taille à qui marilyn monroe
à l'oubli et marilyn monroe sont sales
et cheveux comme ça non c'est pas dit si
tu veux c'est que j'ai
j'étais petit j'étais tellement jamais
tellement les photos de mariés demande
rouge j'aimais tellement ils vivent des
films que aujourd'hui si vous me posez
cette question j'ai plongé un peu plus
vraiment c'est ressembler malignement
droite aurait aimé avoir des gros
nichons fait aborder la terre entière
ouais ouais j'sais pas au bout non non
je suis désolé je vous le permet
un mec t'es pas un mot du tout on a bien
tenté mais christophe quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois
l'impression de tout temps pleurer mais
enfin en fait comme les com mail mais
mais mes larmes ont couverts à
l'intérieur ça ne savent pas quoi 1 quel
péché qui vous tente le plus l'éclair au
chocolat
si c'était à refaire la vie vous feriez
quoi pas pareil je crois que je crois
que je ferais vraiment j'ai vraiment
rêve le plus le plus le plus profond
c'est c'est le voilier donc je crois que
très très tôt un gie aurait appris très
tôt à être qui casquent ces skippers et
puis pour pouvoir me away me barrer joly
est venue d'antoine peut-être pas
vraiment vide et antoine
j'aurais plutôt envie unibet a pris la
tête pour lui voler son bateau voilà
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal en toi qui viens de le dire qu'elle
est la dernière chose que vous faites le
soir avant de vous coucher découpage
vous est découpée quoi par exemple cette
semaine à cette semaine voilà j'ai dit
j'ai découvert ça enfin cette semaine
pour deux soirs
ouais hambourg je vois la découpe et
direction sur pen sur pen
sean penn ouais trucs sur en gros ouais
marcela - qui du coloriage way plein
plein d'autres gens et c'est toujours ce
petit dossier comme ça me fait toujours
avec vous sur dijon mais j'écris tout le
temps il veut relier un truc c'est bien
puisque je fais souvent si bon c j'ai
toujours besoin de petites friandises
avant avant de m'endormir way et donc
j'aime bien les laisser est aussi trop
ah bon c'est marrant c'est la dernière
personne que vous ayez envie de tuer
peut pas répondre à tête avec 14 douanes
pour lui voler son bateau mais ouais
mais c'est tout quoi je veux dire là ça
fait deux fois qu'on dit antoine chez
les n'alerte est-ce que vous avez déjà
pensé au suicide que sauf salut dans mes
rêves glacée de traverser mais je pense
que pour aller au bout
je pense qu'il faut être très fort à moi
je suis très faible christophe est ce
que vous avez menti pendant cette
interview
bien sûr que oui
on va vous